talking about from from the biggest to
the smallest
why do you think the planck scale exists
well um it's an interesting
mathematical fact that if you just take
certain constants of nature that we've
measured
newton's universal gravitational
constant usually called
g h-bar planck's constant
that speaks to the quantum effects and c
the speed of light
if you take these constants and you
combine them in just the right way
you can make the units come out to a
length and the particular length we call
the planck
length and it's a particular number 10
to the minus 33 centimeters
and so so from a from a purely
methodological perspective we understand
why there seems to be a fundamental
length
built into the laws of physics you need
units and those units
are such that they can conspire to yield
this fundamental length scale
from a more philosophical perspective we
suspect it's because
the laws of physics as we understand
them only work
down to a particular length scale as we
probe the universe on ever shorter
scales we've encountered
newer and unexpected phenomenon
but it's possible that the very notion
of a smaller length
doesn't always make any sense there may
come a length
where the notion of a smaller length is
a concept that doesn't mean
anything any longer and if that
idea that chain of reasoning is true
then that is another rationale for the
plank length the plank length would be
that length
below which the notion of below which
doesn't mean anything
and and so if there is such a length the
plank length would be it
it's so cool i saw a um
a theory online where someone said that
the reason the plank length
exists is because we're in a simulation
and that's the size of the pixels
essentially that that's the smallest
amount of bit
information that could be transmitted so
that's that's why it's there
i thought that was quite a cute a cute
way to put it yeah but whenever i hear
things like that
my rejoinder to that is but if he had a
really
clever programmer the programmer could
make the sentient beings
in that simulation think that there
wasn't a plank length
because the programmer is in control of
the reality and therefore can make this
simulance
you and i think whatever the programmer
wants us to think
so i'm less convinced that real
constraints from the physical universe
necessarily have a home in a simulated
universe
or maybe he's put it in as a red herring
so that you think that brian green guy
thinks that he knows what's going on
yes so that's the other the other the
the flip side
is that the simulator can again
conjure things that have no basis in
reality
um so yeah the interplay between
physical reality and the reality that
the simulator creates that's a that's a
subtle one
and i suspect it's in the hands of the
simulator in the hands of the
creator and therefore crossing over
between the two
always feels to me suspect
can you just explain for me the
copenhagen interpretation
i really want to try and cut through
this seems to be like the woo-woo
element of physics that gets thrown
around
and is excuse for all manner of bad
thinking can you just try and break down
what it is and what it isn't
well different people will answer this
question differently in the community
today
so it's not a fully well-defined notion
the
copenhagen interpretation but my view
and it's shared by many other physicists
as well is that look
niels bohr who was one of the founding
pioneers of quantum physics who was
working in copenhagen
had a particular attitude about quantum
mechanics and
any interpretation of quantum mechanics
that captures that
attitude is what we call the copenhagen
approach and his attitude was
quantum mechanics is not about
describing the universe as it
is this is almost a quote of his quantum
mechanics
is about describing the universe as it
is it's all about just making
predictions for what we'll see on
devices on counters
on on measures on instruments
so bohr was basically don't think about
the meaning of quantum mechanics don't
think about the deep nature of reality
just think about quantum mechanics as a
tool
and as a tool you should just use it to
make predictions about
the world and and so he viewed quantum
mechanics as a mathematical algorithm
follow these steps and we can teach
these steps to any undergraduate even
high school kids we can teach them
follow these steps and it will yield a
number
and then compare that number with what
number you get on a dial
and that to me is the most concrete form
of the copenhagen interpretation now
others will say
things like now the copenhagen
interpretation is about you know you
look at an experiment
and that causes the quantum mechanical
wave function to collapse
onto this result or that result and
therefore it's all about an
uh interrelationship between an observer
and the observed
ah yeah i get it some people will say
that
but i don't think bohr ever really felt
that he'd gotten to grips
with that relationship and so i think
the the
most um accurate description
of the copenhagen approach bohr's
approach is just use quantum mechanics
as an algorithm
don't worry about what it means thank
you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace